yeah hello and welcome to this video I
wasn't entirely sure if I had pressed
the button but I had
okay so sorry
first words of this Dame yeah so that's
defense against pay Rosine let's see
okay that's not really great if I
remember correctly the early b5 you know
Black has multiple problems and no space
and weekend queenside but let's see how
to do that and that kind of prompts me
to play a four when you
night before maybe it's this idea that
don't quite know
must be the idea otherwise it makes
absolutely no sense
yeah rookie - I can't even take you on
b5 that it's not totally totally stupid
getting b5 4c - however here he has to
play a six and then the night is also in
slightly slightly weird spot yeah so I
wonder what the best setup is him is it
bishop to the bishop to f3 maybe so that
I'm putting some pressure there and
control d5 long-long yeah that comes B 7
makes actually some sense it looks a bit
odd but it could be okay
yeah I wonder if f6 is never on this
agenda No
okay this threatens 9065 yeah we can't
have two I wanted to play anyway so it
doesn't really matter all that much
yeah he kind of has to do something I
mean if he is just sitting at that won't
cut it okay if I take Bishop to g7 I'm
going to lose that pawn hmm I wonder
yeah I still it looks a little bit
conservative to play g3 but I want you
if I keep f1 d5 I'm keeping him bottled
up here that's difficult for him to move
anything
yeah it's difficult to he would like to
trade something for certain but I don't
really see how night ba da night f8
looks really strange and I have very
simple moves like look H to d1 and night
e to would like to D for a 5 g 3 a 5 if
that hits it's terrible
f 6 I think ok so this is doing what any
of it that should be fun and now I have
a very simple threat a B 5 a B 595 cakes
B should be seven and winning winning at
least upon that is now the simple point
he's running out of options him okay now
I can do what I said but 94-94 you
this is totally devastating it's also 96
now so let's check briefly is there
anything better than Luke f7 No yeah now
if I take aged seven
[Music]
and this is mrs. maybe even better
taking this and getting getting getting
ecigs
I don't know maybe it wasn't better and
I'm not complaining yeah I'm just okay
Luke age seven was pretty awful for him
and I'm not sure that this was indeed
better okay yeah there was a nice
demonstration why b5 is a bit subtle
year in this position yes City is a
probably wrong word but it's just it's
not good simply five it's strong for why
that's one of the points of the apes
remove that you prevent this and now
black is only having yeah bad options
they're relatively best is what the
engine yeah also calculates as before
take-take-take
big and black is a pawn down but it's
one of those double pawns and it's not
um a simple conversion for white yeah
you have to work hard to make the pawn
count but it's obviously a good opening
result for white and not great for black
but this is I think relatively best this
position he has some pool very very tall
autumn is six and that when they form it
can certainly just develop as the
computer suggests but yeah it don't like
it so much
opt eggs headsets good yeah that's very
very typical a computer chess very
concrete he might take it as 95 and I
don't want to give this up at the moment
you but I have to add cannot preserve
the bishop as this all-important pawn is
hanging yeah a six is kind of playing
along my train of thought we're just
comfortably better I think
King F - yeah 95 yeah it isn't it
doesn't work it's still the best line
Wow
giving you the pieces the best line
that's funny
okay yeah here
the alternative to g3 was to take and
play six the reason I did not do that is
that it makes this bishop look a bit
better
oh it's good for white dough but g3 is
this strategically sound I think simply
piling up and black is running our moves
him it's just not a coordinated position
an idea for a strong way I kind of had
the suspicion actually this is stronger
but anyway it if you can net a bran and
it's a good thing so I think it doesn't
matter my share they're all better
I wrote you six I didn't see that okay
that's winning anyway keep black
resigned yeah
b5 s not a good lines is the main point
or the main thing to take from this game
thanks for watching